en deux monstres sacrés se rend compte
ça fait des étincelles c'est ce qu'a pu
constater constaté martin lawrence un
lancement à la jambe me marc florens sur
la wii martin lawrence quand il vous a
vu avec will smith
non mais c'est lui le monstre sacré mark
et sécréter vous bat on a fait ce
lancement mady au lancement jean-mi donc
du coup je répète non merci l'homme et
donc du coup voilà vous avez fait un
petit sketch pour le lancement de la
rivière bad boys et postières et c'est
très drôle exactement c'est vrai que
j'ai rencontré will smith et martin
lawrence
hier c'était à l'hôtel ritz palace
magnifique et c'est vrai que je me suis
régalé je n'appelle pas dans ces cas là
et les deux les deux exceptionnels et
will smith
ça c'est la classe je vous le dis je les
adorais d'ailleurs ben je lui ai dit on
va peut-être se voir quoi avec will
smith
c'est à dire bah se voir comme un par
écran interposé
[Musique]
lula a regretté
al houda la tht l'été midi des plus
tarder
arrêter maintenant je suis ici tu vois
hr du tabasco et vous alors là les deux
stars qu'est-ce que vous deveniez
toujours dans le cinéma comme justin
vient et on fait du sport vous avez pas
bougé ute on trouve vous a fait plaisir
pour trouver 25 ans après l'arrêt de
mort de caisson de basses suivi
et images et un communiqué franchement
vous avez des gags des voix si oui je
vous sers un truc et et si vous prenez
un truc c'est pour moi c'est gratuit en
larmes explique maître de l'apéritif
allongée du bar avec ce barça là
[Applaudissements]
franchement les amours ça a été génial